things in the UK are getting a little
tense and it's all over this thing
dubbed the brexit the UK is planning to
vote on whether to leave the European
Union and much of the debate over
whether to stay has focused on
immigration
I'm all for immigration but this country
is getting a bit too overpopulated I
mean it's just no good their own borders
because all these people coming in
membership in the European Union means
free movement of people between member
countries so anyone from Germany Poland
Greece or any of the other 24 you
countries can move to the UK to live and
work and vice versa in 2015 alone the
number of migrants living in the United
Kingdom increased by one hundred and
eighty four thousand that's five hundred
per day and those pushing to leave the
EU have lashed on to the resulting
tensions by stoking fear of immigrants
and refugees a tender-hearted woman saw
a poor half frozen snake yep that's
Trump in a reversion campaign video
posted by leave dot EU but instead of
saying thank you
that snake gave her a vicious bite
so why the hell are these brits so
terrified of immigrants the anti-eu camp
argues that migrants are a strain on
public finances because some are
entitled to receive free health care
education and other welfare benefits
while in the UK the EU referendum is
about nothing less than the safety and
security of British women no more mrs.
don't know let's get the hell out he was
quoting the words of a reporter there
four British politician Nigel Farage has
been vocal in his fear that staying in
the EU means more migrants and more
migrants equals more sexual assaults on
British women and my national security
we mean fear of Muslims Muslim majority
Turkey has been fighting to join the
European Union for years and some
believe its acceptance is imminent so
probe Exeter's are warning that this
could be the UK's only chance to get out
before the Muslims get in and the leave
campaign hasn't been shy about pointing
out Turkey's proximity to Syria and Iraq
even those who want to stay in the EU
have given in to this fear-mongering and
yes we do need to do things to control
immigration like restricting in-work
welfare but it would be madness to
contrive to do that by trashing our
economy and putting out of the single
market so is the brexit being fueled by
anti-immigrant fear and to keep
insisting that the EU is about economics
is like saying that the Italian mafia is
interested in olive oil and real estate
and that Boris you just might be right
you